اليوم تم اعدام قاتلي نيره اشرف بعد سنه
من تنفيذ جريمته البشعه فبحضور ممثل نيابه
العامه ورجل دين نفذت مصلحه السجون بسجن
جمصه شمال مصر في تمام الساعه السادسه
صباحا من يوم الاربعاء الرابع عشر من
يونيو الاعذاب بحق محمد عادل الذي ادين
بقتل نيره بعد الاعدام تم نقل جثمان عادل
الى مستشفى المنصوره الدولي لتسليمه الى
عائلته استعدادا لدفنه بمقابر العائله لكن
ما الذي وقع قبل تنفيذ حكم الاعدام عادل
ادين بطعم زميلته الطالب نيره وقتلها مع
سبق الاصرار امام بوابه كليه الاداب
بجامعه المنصوره في العشرين من يونيو 2022
حاول لاخر لحظه الافلات من حبل المشنقه
بطعنه بحكم الاعدام لكن القضاء رفض لان كل
الادله تورته وفي زيارتها الاخيره له
طالبت اسره عادل السلطات بايقاف الحكم
وضروره عرض ابنها على مستشفى الامراض
العقليه في المقابل كانت عائله الضحيه
تطالب باذاعه حكم الاعدام على التلفزيون
وتنفيذه بشكل علني حتى يكون راضيا لتكرار
تلك الجريمه